patrick artus a évoqué
par un
peu dedans parce avant peut-être dans
d'horizon
un repas il ya le problème c'est que
l'horizon de tata pas trop votre visite
tu vois est à prévoir le voir on reste
tranquille pouvoir
à l'horizon pour moi voilà top pour le
chemin comme ça quoi
on est un peu de
la ses moyens quand même côté coop ce1
passées vos l'accord par paul vi la
gauche depuis peu fier des trucs ce
qu'on veut que les passages de niveaux
partout
paraissait aux groupes qui est très
belle avec des arbres partout dans l'eau
le faire à ses batteries la présence ou
pas d'un
côté par analogie
vers la gauche provoquant alors un peu
chez passagers là où tu as un parfait
bravo je regarde si tu
gauche
beaucoup d'ailleurs un petit peu à
gauche que façade ou parce qu'on a un
meilleur éclairage tas
était presque plus intéressant que la
vente était ce matin avec le jaune vert
et plus le contraste
a trop peur
et sa tour de plus le foot blanche était
dans le plus j'ai dit
tout ce temps je me demandais que si
vous voulez le faire il ya un bateau le
bateau avec un
s'il ya deux personnes
c'est vraiment le truc de
tout est où là je suis par l'arrière
et ce faire le coach veut ouais
et belleisle bay l'île blanche qui
arrive
alors mettez la base de vos passions
saveurs et cela doit être cet oued sa
voix nouveau duel
dans la salle
bondée simon s arrêter de filmer un peu
plus rude et en contre-jour quand un
joueur est dessus il y
est arrivé là